this is Jocko underground podcast and we
actually have an echo Charles topic
which is strange because you sent you
always send me topics
and look I open them with the I you know
you'll send me an email it'll say
ugtopics sure and I'll open it up with a
good attitude I'll have a positive
attitude cool but
it's been pretty rare so far that they
make the cut now maybe one of our topics
could be Echo Charles topics matter of
fact maybe we'll do that next time I'll
just go through the topics
and see what you were thinking when
these came in mind also I'd like to say
this if there's something that a
listener is that you'd like to hear us
discuss send it in
not just a question but say hey we'd
like to hear your discussion on this
topic
so the topic that you sent me was shot
and freuden
schaden freuda I think that's how you
say it shot and freuda
schadenfreude
you sent me this topic hey let's talk
about this and it's a pretty it's a
pretty popular topic yeah maybe popular
strong words you hear it occasionally uh
it's a German word that's the
combinations of two words the first word
it's Shaden which is damage or harm
and freuda which is Joy so this is when
you as a person are finding joy in
someone else's suffering so
I I it seems to be something that people
like to experience on the interwebs
right you can kind of watch bad things
happen to people I mean there's a whole
there's a thing called fail like fail TV
and fail army records just watching
people eat in a bunch of various
different ways on skateboards on
mountain bikes on water skis in vehicles
that's that's sort of the ultimate form
of schadenfreude right it's kind of well
I mean maybe not the it's the it's a
pure form you are literally watching
people suffer or like when a kid here's
a classic one where the kid swings a bit
you know the dad and the kid right and
then the baseball bat
um or they're playing baseball or
whatever the kid hits the baseball and
hits it Dad in the nuts yeah that's the
classic one classic
so those are kind of
quite frankly those are kind of like a
little bit innocent kind of funny
humorous versions of this but there are
some you know when I when I was looking
this up trying to try to just get a
little more of a better understanding of
it dry the psych the psychological
driving forces because this can be a
real thing psychological driving forces
are aggression rivalry and sometimes
Justice you think about that one well
like when you see here's a classic one
going back to the same kind of
knucklehead stuff
you see the person that's driving
and they do some move and then
they hit a freaking you know a bridge
bunkman or whatever yeah kind of you
know that guy you got what you deserved
so when I worked at the nightclub
downtown you'd you know people show out
downtown right and you say show out yeah
show out like getting all dressed up and
whatnot no it's like is it is it
different than show off yeah a little
bit what's the difference sure it means
like essentially for lack of better way
of putting it making a scene okay good
or bad okay you know
um yeah so guys would like when they
leave they'll peel out right making it
all Smoky and Loud making this just
showing out right okay and uh they peel
out right and then you sometimes because
there's a lot of cops down there you'll
see the cops like you know and go chase
him everyone would cheer it's weird
everyone on the streets cheering
just shot and Afraid all day
Justice for that person so that can do
it
and so why did you what made you want to
discuss this
um was it some particular case that you
saw no no it was just like the like a
psychological kind of condition that's
like it seems bad but then there's it
probably goes so deep in which to me I
didn't know I didn't realize all of this
stuff that you already said yeah well
here's what when you asked about it's
like Okay cool so we'll talk about what
it is and I think everyone can kind of
understand it but I wanted to take
something I want to say positive way
from but I wanted to get a legitimate
lesson learned from it here's the
legitimate lesson learned as I started
thinking about this feeling
it is such a good indicator
of your own
station in life your own security your
own confidence your own for lack of
everybody word happiness right so if I'm
seeing Echo and I see you freaking
whatever you get uh you you crash your
car and I'm like I kind of feel good
about it what does that say about me if
I see if you get fired from your job
if your girlfriend dumps you and I kind
of feel good about it
why why is that well it's because I'm
insecure it's because I'm not happy and
I want you to be suffering as well
you know I got for a while thinking that
you know certain guys in the SEAL Teams
wouldn't want to see other guys succeed
I told you that story about Seth wanting
to go to Princeton and guys like no you
shouldn't go to ruin your career I'm
like bro how is going to Princeton gonna
ruin your career what are you that's
insane like go to Princeton you'll have
a degree but people didn't want him to
get that leg up right so it's sort of
like a check engine light for your soul
and if you're walking around and you see
other people suffering and it brings you
Joy you got issues that you need to look
at for yourself and you need to check
yourself now there's a once I got in the
rabbit hole of this thing there's
another word
another tough to pronounce German word
but it's related it's called glucksmirtz
and what this is
this is when you're mad about someone
else's good luck
oh Echo got a new job you're mad about
it yeah you know oh Echo just freaking
got a new house and you're mad about it
same thing in my opinion
if you feel this way you need to check
your soul this is a red light end to
check engine light on your soul I I when
I got the house that I live in now which
was a long time ago it was actually 10
almost 12 almost 11 years ago I got the
house I live in now house I live in now
is in a cool very cool location I could
barely afford it I did crazy things to
get into that house
and one of the you know not like a close
friend but uh you know friend of the
family type
individual
that stop you know was walking down the
street and knew that we had gone or
whatever and walked in there and
immediately
started telling me like oh the traffic
you know it's going to be loud hello
there's a lot of salt corrosion Because
by the oil like just point out all these
negative things started hating us all
was hating thank you for bringing us the
parlance of our times right was hating
on it you could not be mad at this house
I mean unless you're you could not be
you know it's it
you could not be
and I remember thinking damn this dude
is bummed that I got it that I got this
house in this location so what's so
what's that the location right the house
was kind of crappy
wasn't that crappy though I mean it was
not bad it wasn't heinous yeah was
livable
you know what I'm saying but the
location yeah was good to go
so
but then the funny thing is Stoner came
by
and I was like hey dude I got I got
because I didn't want to jinx it and so
I told him I'm like hey man I'm I'm in
escrow for a house he's like where is it
I'm like oh and I was like oh it's it's
down by the water will be you know but I
didn't want to tell them because I want
to jinx it yeah Superstition style so
finally I gotta go I go hey man come and
see the new house and he's like where is
it I sent him like the pin drop and he's
like damn so he comes over and I'm
already there
and he walks in dude and you could see
like big SMO ear-to-ear a smile on his
face he's like dude we're set for him it
was like we bought it it was our house
you know what I'm saying but he was like
super stoked he had the opposite of good
schmirtz
so
if you're one of these people if you're
getting bitter
then then you have an issue
and where I I said again you kind of
sent me in a little bit of a thought
tornado
because here's what's going on in my
opinion once again if I'm looking at you
and I'm kind of mad that you're getting
lucky when I look at myself I realize
there's I'm not I'm letting myself down
somehow right
um
I'm bummed like I remember actually you
know Stoner ended up getting a house
in the neighborhood that I was in and it
wasn't quite as badass but it was
freaking legit
and I was so stoked for him
so he was talking for me I spoke for him
right that's the way it's supposed to be
some people be all bummed out when their
friends are winning yeah if you're
bummed out when your friends are winning
you're probably you got issues but I
think the issue that you have is you're
not doing what you're supposed to be
doing you're not working hard you're not
Reaching Your Potential
and that is so you have the pent-up
aggression towards people that are being
successful and that's a bummer
so watch out for this again I think both
these things they're good things to pay
attention to because if you're feeling
them if you're feeling Joy when someone
is suffering
or you're feeling anger when someone is
winning you got issues pay attention to
it yeah
do you feel like a little bit of that is
natural
well that's the thing there are natural
psychological driving forces that I that
I read about which is you know our
natural human aggression right like
we're sizing each other up
we're we're compa we're competitors in
life right that's what I feel like so
that is a natural thing that we're going
to have we have a natural rivalry for
resources and for you know mates at an
animal
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
8.18 cents a month and if you can't
afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground